welcome back to the second round of the
sinkfield cup and we have a very special
guest here with us musical director and
creative in Residence Brian Owens
pleased to have you here on I know
everybody's like who is this guy no no
no no you've been on before Brian you
were the guy who did the Bobby Fisher
song I was there yeah I had a beard
didn't know I looked like a totally
different person you did but you but for
me that was one of the most creative
songs I've ever heard
no no that was absolutely extraordinary
every time I try to create a song I
can't do anything every time I try to
play we're all in the you managed to
link the two
right I think there are a lot of
correlations between chess and music
that I found over the years and
specifically since I started working at
the world chest Hall of Fame I mean
they're both Universal languages they
both you know have a it requires both
creative uh and you know a certain level
of intelligence to do both of them and
so I mean I I have a deep appreciation
for chess though I'm not a great chess
player what I'm finding is a lot of the
folks who play our music series they are
chess players yeah it's pretty cool it's
pretty cool yeah yeah yeah how cool is
that and recently we had coming to St
Louis the musical chess which I went it
was so good it was it was magical the
nights were fantastic yeah and I went
into it you know I've been going to the
mun a long time it was actually the best
show that I've seen at the mun wow in
all my in all my years of coming and um
I every year on a date with my choir
teacher from high school really yeah and
so she was said well let's go see chess
and we went to go see it and we were
both kind of like we'll see what happens
and by the end we're like this is
probably the best music we've seen here
yeah yeah the story Line's great and and
the music is great I love the song
Anthem um just this expression of of
country and it it's really cool man I
like it one night in backcock man yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was just as we
were coming on show I was just saying to
Brian that I actually was in Morano in
1980 and my guy Victor kcho I was
working with Victor kchoi and in the bar
uh I spent you know three hours talking
to a guy who's doing a musical on chess
I just thought it was the dumbest idea I
ever heard in my life I mean you know
imagine a business venture Brian I like
come Brian I need you to do a musical on
chess you go to a tournament like this
silence silence don't talk no talking no
no talking a lot it's in the rules you
can't till the end of the night and you
find out that it's Tim Rice exactly you
just casually dropped that man Tim Rice
I like wait a minute Andrew Lloyd Weber
Jesus Christ Superstar I can't believe
you he tried to sabotage one of the
greatest mus musical of
all and what about Chess no less out of
principle you should have been like yeah
that's good that's good you got this
what's coming up uh at the World Chess
Hall of Fame in the musical series we
got a great season next year with a lot
of uh you know locally based talent that
you know has a world renown a claim and
we're really excited about that really
excited about the diversity that we're
bringing into the Hall of Fame and the
chess really excited about the Gayla
this year myself yeah CU myself and
Brian Woods who's the other musical
director we're going to be hosting and
again I think you know the the world has
now come to St Louis for chess um but I
think we forget that you know a lot of
the music that's in the world came from
Louis and so now being able to make that
correlation of Excellence on the campus
of world CH Hall of Fame which we feel
like is is a place of Excellence I think
it's really cool yeah well St Louis the
home of the Blues but you also you don't
just create you perform
sometimes tell you're great let's take a
look at Brian performing
[Music]
oh I can you
make broken
heart how can you stop the rain from
falling
down tell me how can you
stop that old
sunshine I got to say Brian that bearded
look is very very different from Studio
shout out to Al Green 1972 that's why we
did that cuz it was the same year as the
spasy Fisher so that's why we um did
that song and uh Ryan so tell us about
your role as a music director and
creative in residence for the World
Chess Hall of Fame like yeah like I was
saying ear I love what I get to do I get
to find these correlations between the
world of Chess and the world of Music we
try to help a lot of young creatives
with this idea of strategizing their
lives strategizing their careers and
chess is a perfect backdrop for that um
and again just the way we're we're
getting to integrate a lot more
diversity into people who are sometimes
coming to the campus for the first time
through the music series but then you
know are able to find out all of the
other many wonderful things that we
offer at the chess club and you know
through the Galleries at the hall of
fame so it's really cool and you
mentioned the wild Chess Hall of Fame
music series what makes it so special I
think what makes it special is the level
of Excellence right the and the place
that we're providing for folks not only
who are in St Louis but from around the
world to come um be treated with with
the respect that their talent deserves
and for audiences to be up close and
personally intimate it's like like the
chess tournaments that you have right
like you get you get to be almost like
you're there with them in the game and I
think you know from a creative
standpoint it's really cool for audience
to get that experience well the intimacy
between the musician in the audience is
right there it's fantastic and uh I when
I go to the uh series uh the ones that
I've gone through uh quite a number of
people from Symphony uh perform as
well it's great well I mean and just
like you know you know the World Chess
Hall of Fame and the in the chess club
has brought so many amazing talented
chess ambassadors to to the city who now
call the city home and I think the same
is true for musicians and and active
artists and creatives in our city I mean
they they perform all over the world so
to get them in a room of 75 of our
closest friends right cuz that's what it
feels like too right yeah and to to to
play music at the highest level to play
original music that they that they made
it's special yeah and uh you're co-
mcing strategy across the board on
December second what can we look forward
to you got to get your tickets
tiet yeah it's it's going to be it's
going to be a lot of fun with myself and
Brian Woods and I mean just celebrating
the the the the tenure of of this great
organization in the community the work
that's been done scholastically with
chess and what we hope to do moving
forward with with music and and bridging
those things and marrying them together
I think this year's Gayla is going to
really shine a beautiful light on that
and this is the Gayla coming it's our
big fundraiser it's our annual
fundraiser strategy cost board Marina
will be there of course as a special
guest and all take place December 2nd
and we're going to combine also the
closing ceremony so we're going to a lot
of the chess Grand Masters uh with this
the other Brian I wanted to put it like
that the other Brian that uh works at
the World Chess Hall of Fame the music
series he was telling me about getting a
performer and it was crazy the performer
was going to New York and d and it was
like there was only one date that he
could perform in St Louis and he said
book me book me I want it it was like
the musicians now want to meet the chess
players too right because he plays chess
who was from
Russia
yeah petroi uh they had done so never
mind sorry but yeah he's a really good
musician it was really great it was
really great and uh I think that's cool
that the musicians want to come and be a
part of the chess scene well but if you
look at if you look at the exhibit that
that we have now I mean you see so many
musicians who you know back in the day
you you know Neil Diamond on the cover
of a magazine he's playing chess or Ray
Charles was an amazing not just Avid
chess but a really good chess player so
I I I don't think that we we can look at
the and and see some kind of cognitive
distance but it's like it's really not
actually makes a lot of sense for people
who are high level musicians and
creatives to also be lovers and engag in
chess yours truly not not that number um
but yeah yeah yeah when I can beat my
5-year-old daughter then I'm like good
I'm good but I remember Ray Charles with
a bra set right thank you so much
for it's brilliant I'm looking forward
to the Gaya night it's going to be
absolutely I may make you sing with me
no don't you dare
please we have people leaving the show
early this gentleman has a fine
voice uh we're going to take a look at
our
standings right
now as after to round one and there you
can see that after yesterday's